le siège social du cn a beau être situé
sur la rue de la gauchetière à montréal
depuis six décennies
la direction de la plus grande compagnie
de chemin de fer au canada n'a pas
trouvé de francophones pour siéger à son
conseil d'administration
le cn se défend en disant qu'il s'agit
d'une situation temporaire par voie de
communiqué l'entreprise indique que le
conseil d'administration est hautement
conscient des enjeux l'absence
d'administrateurs francophone sera réglé
dans la prochaine année j'ai été honnête
j'ai été époustouflé ce au prix chocs et
justin trudeau s'attend ce que le cn
réajuste le tir rapidement je comprends
à quel point les gens sont frustrés moi
aussi je le suis alors j'ai demandé au
ministre approprié de s'assurer que la
cn travail rapidement pour rectifier la
situation je suis deux oreilles d'autant
plus difficile à comprendre dit le
premier ministre alors qu'il ya quelques
semaines le pdg d'air canada a dû
s'expliquer devant le comité permanent
sur les langues officielles pour avoir
prononcé un discours uniquement en
anglais devant des gens d'affaires de
montréal c'est dans la culture berkane
nador dans la culture du canadien
national mais le gouvernement ne prêche
pas par exemple dit le chef du bloc
québécois il faudra mettre tout en haut
de la liste des dénonciations du manque
de considération pour les francophones
la gouverneure générale du canada et la
lieutenant gouverneur du nouveau
brunswick qui sont des unilingues
anglophones ou qui ne parle assurément
pas le français au delà de la
dénonciation la pression du monde des
affaires a plus de poids pour cet expert
peut penser à une pression de la part
des investisseurs de certains
actionnaires qui pourraient faire
entendre leur voix qui pourraient
éventuellement également à l'assemblée
annuelle faire entendre leur
mécontentement
en tout cas le bureau du premier
ministre du québec lui a fait savoir son
mécontentement et semble avoir obtenu
satisfaction ne pas rouler à direction
cm et la semaine prochaine ils vont
annoncer qu'ils vont nommer quelqu'un de
québécois et francophones